Organized Crime, a Constant Worry.
Organized crime is a worldwide phenomenon that governments and societies are constantly struggling to control.
There is some nostalgia concerning the organized crime of the Prohibition Era in America,...
...but this stems mainly from the reality that Prohibition was widely unpopular.
Those who were operating outside the law to provide alcohol for the masses...
...were actually viewed as doing a service, rather than breaking the law.
Once Prohibition ended in America,...
...organized crime in America started to lose its glamour,...
...and began to reduce the quality of life in communities which it was most active in.
Nowadays, parents who live in urban low income areas...